I think I could eat everything except
dog yeah I like horse but I think I
can't eat it all right here we go
three I tried it to be good I wouldn't
eat it wow it's really good the action
[Music]
no shortcuts news submitted by Jay loves
JK thank you
two women were hospitalized after trying
to end their periods early with a
vacuum-cleaner
bid what did she do get a shot back and
put it our [ __ ] literally yeah period
out did not understand how menstrual
cycles wait wait do they don't have a
ShamWow maybe I don't understand how
menstrual cycle works isn't it like the
blood accumulates and then it just like
falls down as the period goes and tissue
chill I'm not saying that what they did
is right but if that's how it goes
wouldn't that make sense for them trying
to lay back you mean I just attached
around the uterus yeah layer and then
lining it like coming out just like
Shetty that's why it takes time
yep it's like it's not like you're just
go no no got it
it's not like vomiting in your [ __ ] you
might feel the same this is not this
nurse from Seattle she tweeted out I
thought she did ladies please stop using
your vacuum hose to end your period
early multiple days you're gonna wind up
sucking out a lot more than blood oh
there were two cases of this so far this
week and both women had to be admitted
just stop what could they suck out more
than blood your vagina can go inside out
and it will like fought through the hole
oh my god I saw that in a porno one time
I have to what what the [ __ ] Joe what
did you look uh I don't look for things
things happen what he always finds the
good [ __ ] hold on what explain it no
like there's like swollen vaginas like
they get like those pumps and then they
suck it out
it looks like really fast you know I
heard that that's how they create a
penis for it like a trans sector but
they do it through surgery usually China
to come out yeah I just look swollen and
it's like a little inside skin layer
that goes out I've heard of that it's
gross though for buttholes and they call
it Rio's buddy yeah I mean it could
happen to our buttholes yeah but it's
really gross it's holes like that okay I
do know that when ladies have helic it's
like you know like when you have more
than six or five or whatever like it
just starts getting loose down there and
like literally I've heard that old
ladies can be walking around and it just
goes yeah what are you talking about you
know their bladder the bladder come I
thought it was over China like it comes
out their skirts like out of the hole
like it's like yeah that's wrong having
like two kids and let's see I've seen
some alleys in my time od lips or you
talking about the vagina oh man it feels
like a war story but I mean yeah I've
seen some some danglers maybe it was me
sandwich
that's labia do it but no that's normal
that's normal that's normal that's just
extra skin yeah even I know that and I'm
not a lady yeah yeah I see there's just
so many different types of vaginas
there's a ton of vaginas yeah look like
danglers yeah I don't have a dangler and
it was I was just as surprised when I
saw it and I was like is this normal but
it's very normal I got you what we're
talking about Thank You vaginas we're
still on the thing I know we got stuck
it out said not to suck it out I'm just
kept thinking about what he was talking
wills beef okay so yeah the nurse said I
heard it feels good even though it
doesn't look good
is it true why yeah feels good for who
look I
it doesn't feel extra skin I heard that
guys who are not circumcised can please
women better really yeah cuz I'm not so
good for skin cuz I know I heard it
feels better for the guy because it's
sensitive and he's not like rubbing on
it is there anything else that matters
all I know is I heard that the the
impotence
or like all that stuff happens because
of circumcision because your dick head
loses all the nerves while you're
growing up that's what I heard but I
think it's stress from old age what I
just saw on the sidebar because we
talked about once how you've never hear
about two guys in one girl having a
relationship and I just saw that anyway
I'm getting distracted so what I've seen
a porno like that though I saw we're
like in the relationship because usually
if you just see a Christian threesome
anyway the nurse continuous she said I
don't know if it was if it was Eureka
Dyson Hoover or some Walmart brand but
yes an actual vacuum cleaner your period
has it has a steady flow of its own for
all intents and purposes your body can
tolerate a vacuum increases the flow
over 1,000 times which your body can't
tolerate therefore sending you into
shock I love a woman having her it's
going through her period she opens her
closet up and she looks at her vacuum
cleaner she's like I'll try it do it I
just can't imagine like okay have you
guys heard her brain like using the
vacuum earthing you put it on your skin
it's like okay imagine that's me all the
time it must hurt I'm just that because
I've heard so many stories of guys
putting their dicks in vacuum you're
finally happy girls are doing that I
love it that's such a guy thing to do
it's the most guy thing ever I saw a
girl play with the vacuum cleaner and it
seemed enjoyable yeah this thing it's
called you menstral an extraction was it
like attachment like you could buy it is
a type of manual vacuum aspiration
technique developed by feminist
activists anything developed by phantom
feminist activism it [ __ ] [ __ ] up man
you gotta watch out you got to go
through scientists my activists so the
non-medical eyes technique they're just
developing [ __ ] through feelings
frienda that's such a bad move I can't
even defend so they're saying that this
technique has been used in small
feminist self-help groups since 1971 and
has a social role of allowing access to
early abortion without needing medical
assistance or legal approval waiting
their period so wait so the menstrual
extraction it seems like it was
developed for abortion it started that
way yeah cuz the whole like abortion
okay this makes sense now I'll take it
back so then they're saying that any
usage declined after 1973 when Roe
versus Wade legalized abortion in the
u.s. model of things so how did these
girls get a hold of that not technology
they use an actual vacuum the nurse said
I guess they're thinking like well if it
was possible to do an abortion with it
then it'll probably take out like my
period to get it over with
it looks like also it's an actual thing
this is for the 1971 thing I see so
they're talking about the origins of
this yeah oh it has no connection to
what the girls are no okay okay maybe it
does like maybe they've heard of this
and the main idea yeah and they made
their own Mickey Mouse version of it
feels like a Dustbuster or something
like the rest of it I hope it wasn't a
shots back sure those are strong they're
really strong so the rest of the
Wikipedia little paragraph that says
there has been a renewed interest in the
technique in the 1990s and more recently
into 2010 due to increased restrictions
on abortion in some countries where
abortion is illegal such as Bangladesh a
similar technique called menstrual
regulation or menstrual extraction are
used as euphemisms for early pregnancy
termination
I'm all for abortion because it keeps
the crime rate low me too not crime rate
yeah it's it's it's it's uh cuz I'm
wanted babies are not born basically
there's this whole book and stuff called
Freakonomics oh I've never even omits
ever in high school okay so they found
out that the crime rate drastically
dropped because people started to do
abortions and then like you know women
didn't have kids at a young age with
without fathers and then like you know
usually they grow up in a bad
environment so those boys
come gangsters and stuff like that make
sense but in this case it's like more
women from the ghetto we're able to get
abortion and then further their
education and change stuff and then so
there weren't that many unwanted babies
I just don't even understand if we're
gonna get into a topic why it's even a
discussion at this point in the 2010
because of religion and church and state
right right but then yeah and it depends
on when people think life is life I
watched this thing on you - I don't know
if you guys have ever seen it but it's
like they get two groups of total
opposite like being star like for
example pro-choice and pro-life the
Jubilee project yeah that's our friends
oh is it and so like they did that one
and it's crazy when you actually talk to
someone who feels so differently than
you yeah and I never knew that was it
sounds silly but if thing anti was it
yeah you kind you have to get the other
perspective yeah and it's [ __ ] insane
how some of these women what they think
and they're entitled to think that but
I'm just like like I guess shocked that
the world's different a hundred percent
different you know what I mean you sure
do they say what happened to the girls
like what Sarah bodies went into shock
because of the thing that's pretty dumb
they had to be admitted that's all you
know oh and I do know their ages it was
nineteen and twenty three years oh no
they're telling you not to do SH like
they taught like they tell girls turn on
Jewish like your body will like
naturally yeah what is do she is like a
vagina douching is like this thing where
you basically put like you wash the
inside of your vagina so like you're
literally washing it you know I can
stick your fingers in yeah and like with
soap and stuff and you don't have to do
that because your body naturally like
just releases flow and like yes is that
a douche bag is douche bags like a guy
who skateboards originally originally I
think that's what it is it's literally
like a little thing that you put into
your vagina and you clean it up and then
you were like put water in it and stuff
yes this is small that I came to
producing the vagina yeah more common
knowledge cool yeah I thought it was
common knowledge but I mean it's just
that's a douchebag cave yeah that's what
that is
Oh anyway you were saying oh yeah but I
was just saying like I you would figure
that if they tell girls to not do should
um their vaginas you much model pick my
nose pick my ear pick my nothing I just
let nature handle it
I guess I could understand the thought
process behind someone who would do it
because they're like well your [ __ ] is
not saying don't even brush your teeth
do people do so maybe it's okay like
they don't take it a step further to
actually look into a douching or this
douching oh okay okay and and this thing
like I just didn't think such a kid I
just want you guys to keep saying
douching how do people used to wipe
their ass the other day I decided to not
wipe and just jump in the shower yeah
because I don't want to waste paper and
I was already talking waste paper yeah
but then I said while I was walking to
the shower I was thinking you know in
ancient times they didn't have toilet
paper what did they do maybe they went
in the river
what if they live in a desert yeah you
can live in a desert and why use that
silk scarf no societies than this I
needed water to live though so then I
assumed they probably just put it on the
butt a little bit
well then every animal doesn't need
paper if you think about it like what do
monkeys do they lick their own butt dogs
are like the sphincter that just [ __ ]
it's so tight it just goes Boop and it
just cuts it off and it's clean monkeys
are very open-minded do they do the
thing where they [ __ ] rub their ass
on the floor they crawl it yeah oh yeah
dogs did yeah now I don't know cuz I
mean oh no animals have they just done
like they're just made and then they can
just [ __ ] make a walk they could do
whatever but we have to clean our bed
yeah I love dogs
yeah but he smells bad don't wipe that's
the what's a rough feeling bro
it is that smells like damn how did the
early humans do it I don't know I don't
know what did they do
dude I that's what I always think about
when I think about old battlefields in
my man there's a lot of people [ __ ]
pooping everywhere yeah well that's me
diseases because you weren't cleaning
what a waste of cotton
[Music]